there's less than a month to go before
britain scheduled departure from the EU
and the union is staking out its final
positions on the terms of withdrawal my
guest this week here in Brussels is the
Belgian MEP Philippe Lambert's
who sits on the European Parliament's
brexit steering committee as the EU
negotiated in good faith and is that
famous unity of the 27 beginning to
crack
[Music]
Philipp Lahm bats welcome to convict
zone thank you let's talk first about
brexit if we may and the possibility
that Britain might seek an extension of
the article 50 process you said the
other day an extension must be
accompanied by a credible plan for
holding a people's vote on the final
deal that includes an option to remain
in the EU well that's my preference but
there's no there must be a credible plan
but since when is it your job to tell
the British people that they should have
another vote on the referendum I'm not
taking it on I'm not telling them I know
that might be the most they must my my
people in Britain tell me that's what
they want my allies in Britain the
greens the SNP and the Welsh party do
want these people support them some
people do right I know but my people in
Britain one stick you but you come out
and say this and you're interfering in
the democratic processes of the seat I'm
just speaking out my mind I'm not
instructing the Brits what to do what
I'm saying is that if they want an
extension they need to say for what and
it can be a people thought it can be a
new election it it must be we need some
time to other I should they say for what
Angela Merkel says that they should have
their extension we're not going to say
no to it she says there should be an
orderly brexit I agree with that for the
for for Britain but not at any cost
not at any cost because I know it's in
everybody's interest isn't it you don't
notice a you don't want to see an
orderly but not just not just any
orderly brixi just imagine that we do it
the way the ERG wants us to do it
basically what they want us is to open a
550 kilometres back door into the single
market uncontrolled and policed and that
anything simply not true that is and
that is simply not true
they've offered all kinds of means of
checking what goes through these borders
you must begin including a common
rulebook whereby they would agree by
treaty to harmonize the Z answers with
the ERT humours eveything you're talking
about the European research examines a
Tory government I'm talking about the
government a British government I mean
you go ran saying that Britain wants you
to stop policing your borders no they've
offered you they've offered you a number
of different ways they've offered
King what goes not order absolutely not
and this is why they have it's the
reason I suggested I'm sorry to say it's
not because you say something that it is
true it's not because you say that
they've offered controls that it is true
they've just said maybe technology will
save us you know what I work 22 years
I will turned when he turned down the
technological suggestions exactly
because because the suggestions made you
because this is fantasy you can say
they're fantasy you can not like them
but don't say that they weren't offered
they were or from it if I offer you a
double Sun in the sky I can say that it
doesn't make it happen mr. Lambert's
this is the key sticking point the Irish
border the border between the Irish
Republic and Northern Ireland if Britain
crashes out without a deal day one on
this border what happens there will be
controls putting up those controls well
both sites will need to put process it
isn't an island says it isn't of course
it isn't well we will need to have
contingency plans for that of course so
what are they our contingency day one
from day one of course you don't expect
that smugglers will start importing
goods into Europe because at the moment
we have alignment but very soon if this
border is not policed well it will be
abused and all right ve use plans then
what do you believe that we are going to
put these plans in the ocean to 208
border crossing yes and you propose to
police all those to you well we will
need to control we will need to come
against the wishes of the Irish State
against the wishes of the Irish they've
made it perfectly clear what we are
saying is very clear this from Simon
compañía the foreign minister the Irish
government will not support the
re-emergence of border infrastructure on
this island can it be clearer than that
no it cannot be clearer than that but
then they know the consequences that
then we will put the Czechs Elsword and
on the intra Irish border who who will
put the check well the European Union
member states what you what do these
checks look like then who's gonna put
them up front X naught front X I mean
the customs the the custom sort of
authority in the various Member State
I mean what you believe do you believe
that we are going to let any good enter
the European Union just unchecked and so
if if the Ares don't do it then of
course people on the continent will so
there will be a border between Ireland
and other land and you and I tell you
that the Republic of Ireland is very
much preoccupied about the integrity of
the single market and doesn't want to be
excluded from the single markets and
believe me and this is the calculus that
many British are just ignoring is that
yes a heart breaks it will be damaging
for the you 27 it will be even more for
the UK but that is not our problem it
will be damaging for the 27 but well
this lose-lose as Simon Cove Nissa Nissa
lose-lose absolutely but then again
disintegrating the single market just so
pleased EOG will be even more damaging
and between two evils we have to choose
the lesser one so it's a choice between
the Good Friday Agreement and the single
market then isn't it
well it isn't for free you warn Dublin
that if it came to a choice between
those two things you would decide that
the single market was more important
well we will disseminate that way our
receiver ate that plane I mean the
British the British politicians remind
us too often and not anything about the
British position - about what you I'm
talking to you you decide whether you
want to listen or not I mean I don't
care I mean that's your point you want
an answer I give it to you I mean the
Brits are responsible for the Good
Friday Agreement we are not I mean the
two parties - the Good Friday Agreement
are the Republic of Ireland and the
United Kingdom and I mean it is a
responsibility of the United Kingdom to
stand by its word and what ye are G is
not doing and what the extremists the
extreme break cities are doing is
basically reaching the Good Friday
Agreement using it you cannot tell the
agreement you were as we but we cannot
defend it if one of the two parties -
the Good Friday Agreement doesn't rise
give Ireland a choice don't you good
friday I mean the Brits or the
single-mother Brits have to make up
their minds whether they want to stand
by an agreement an international
agreement that they slide it is their
responsibility
you told an audience in Dublin that if
the Irish government said to hell with
the single market let's keep the Good
Friday Agreement at any cost
well there'll be 26 other member state
who won't see it too that way exactly so
you're opening up a huge rift between
Ireland and the rest of the US for it
for again the two parties to the Good
Friday Agreement to decide what they
want to do but the prime responsibility
lies with the British government and the
British Parliament because they are the
ones who have sucked the very basis of
the the foundation on which I could try
the agreement is built that is the
common membership of both the Republic
and the United Kingdom to the European
Union it is what made possible the Good
Friday Agreement if the Brits remove
their part of the foundation they have
to replace it with something you really
went to threaten Ireland no your message
to Dublin was clear the --use interests
are more important than yours no we are
not just saying we are just saying that
we have a responsibility for the single
market Ireland and United Kingdom have a
responsibility for the Good Friday
Agreement we'll do everything we can
within the space of reason to support
the Good Friday Agreement but if one of
the two parties so the Good Friday
Agreement breaks it what can we do what
can we do and just a ram home your
message to the Irish you gave the
example of the Greek crisis where you
said the EU did it did whatever it took
to keep the integrity and would do
whatever it took interesting that you
mentioned the example of Greece because
it's one of the great examples of how
the EU was willing to trash the economy
of a member country and humiliate its
people simply to keep its precious rules
intact and you were basically offering
the same to Ireland weren't you
no no whatever the cost to you will do
it will keep the single market intact
and I think and I have reasons to think
that the Irish government also wants to
keep the integrity of the single market
believe me and look what look what your
measures did to Greece one in three - my
tea used measures I don't know who you
are but I was new even to a group I was
not part well we fought against these
measures one isn't three living below
the poverty line some 500 more suicides
registered a moment when - in 2009 this
is how you impose your rules on the
countries in the or you're talking at
the EU you know I'm asking you
the troika I know that took over the
economy
I'm Ida troika a mighty European Union
no but you went to say to Ireland that
they would use the same priorities to
keep the single mighty in fact I take my
cue from history and when the European
Council wants to keep the integrity of
the monetary you know single market
their determination is complete I'm not
ahead of Satan and government I am a
member of the European Parliament I will
never accept to be taken well made
accountable for policies decided by
politicians which with whose political
orientation I don't share as you know if
you follow green policies that we fought
against the memoranda that were imposed
on on on Greece all along because we
know that the Greek rescue plants were
actually rescue plans for Deutsche Bank
fobian paper he before kadia Jekyll and
ankle you know that so if you want to
make me appear as if I were mister
troika mr. European Council well this is
this is a game right so no I'm not a
player in that game sorry so you're
against maintaining the integrity of the
single market at any cost are you what
are you playing at are you I'm asking
you what I'm saying no I want to keep
the integrity of the single market
I don't want whatever the cost to the
Member State not whatever the cost to
the member state but the actually what
you are asking if if I may is basically
that we we give way to the most extreme
break cities in the UK who want a kick
in it is why should we do it well if you
end up with no deal on brexit because
neither side has blinked your rules the
--use rules will have served no useful
purpose were they they would have taken
everybody to a place they don't want to
get to know that lose lose lose
situation as their I think that I've
taken you to that I think that the
heartbreak did tears want to go there
and find by me I mean they do whatever
they like if they have a majority in
parliament to do that Who am I to oppose
this but I do believe that the vast
majority of British citizens don't want
that to happen let them manifest
themselves through their representatives
in the House of Commons
if rules don't produce winners was of
having well don't you believe that the
singer market produces winners I mean we
are better off with a single market in a
globalized economy generally in this in
if everybody will lose from we would
lose from the outcome if Britain crashes
out and there's no deal if every they
lose from that what use of the rules do
you then go and say to Europe ah we kept
our rules in tap but never mind
I mean they've lost that badly and we're
losing out bad everybody loses let me
let me just remind you one thing
is that if we destroy the single market
just to please the heartbreak city as
the damage will be an order of magnitude
bigger so yes it's an evil yes it's a
lose-lose situation but giving the
extremists their way would be massively
more damaging and yes we would never
prefer to avoid brexit but if it comes
to that well we will choose the form of
break seed that is the least damaging
the damage there will be you cut off
your nose to spite your face you'll do
something that even damages you as well
well we are protecting or interest as
best as we can those who caused the
damage in the first place are those who
chose to interpret the results of the
referendum in the most extreme way there
was not one way to interpret the result
of the referendum a form of exit had to
be negotiated quite obviously there was
a mandate 45248 to do that but nothing
nothing tomorrow is messy democracy is
messy you say it exactly when the Prime
Minister said we are going to be out of
the single market and customs union and
jurisdiction of the ECG and everything
we are going to respect the Good Friday
Agreement and we are going to have no
divergence between Northern Ireland and
the rest of the UK you know what she was
just saying something that was
impossible I mean these three things are
mutually exclusive I mean it's not
because you say and you keep repeating
them that you make them possible I mean
when they are mutually exclusive they
are and and actually the the predicament
of Teresa may is one of her own making
she decided to go that way she could
have chosen a different interpretation
of brexit and actually what the hundreds
it is fail to recognize is that many
promises they made during the campaign
were made were actually made impossible
by the existence of the Good Friday
Agreement I want to move on because I
want to talk about prioritizing rules
ahead of results no no no no it's
prioritizing results ahead of rules look
at the security arrangements for
instance new security arrangements
between the EU and the UK and the haste
in which the EU is going to cut Britain
out of databases Shannon danger face and
Europe Oh database how does that serve
the security interests of Europe
prioritizing rule those rules and
procedures over safety and security
because the EU will be less secure
without Britain as a bad part of that
system and Britain will be less secure
it may well be but are you prepared to
have that you could prioritize the facts
say how are we going to get the best
deal we have then again
I'm sorry too instead of just cutting
them out of the databases I don't know
what game you are playing but the point
is that you fail to recognize that the
European Union has a value in itself the
single market has a value in itself in
terms of providing leverage right and
basically what you say is that for
short-term expediency we should
sacrifice the leverage the safety of
Europeans is short-term experience
absolutely because you really achieve a
single you can achieve the same goal
while keeping the integrity of the
European Union the United Kingdom can
have security agreement with the Union
but these need to be negotiated if the
United Kingdom wants to become a third
state fine but that it will be treated
as a third state and we will have
bilateral negotiations and we'll see
what comes out the Lambert's where
Europe Oh is concerned about 40% of
everything that you're about does is
linked to work that is either provided
or requested by the UK in 20 set is one
area where the UK invested in a new
institution in 2017 the UK contributed
over 6,000 piece of information to
Europe bonus more than any other country
yeah and you will lose that by
necessarily but we will negotiate it out
we will negotiate we will negotiate but
do you think that negotiation starts by
accepting what's your opposite number
wants no that's not how it works I've
negotiated long enough in my life to
know that the negotiation starts when
the customer says no right and he tends
when the customer says yes what
negotiators seem to obsess about is that
Britain must appear to lose know from
this absolutely not a view has made it
clear that leave leaving the EU is a
mistake and that should become a
self-fulfilling prophecy now know
Britain has to lose know whoever loses
Britain has to lose I mean you play the
ERG part but but that again is a lunacy
I mean no we just say that membership of
the European Union has benefits and of
course if you're not remember you don't
enjoy those benefits it's not punishment
it's just a no my point is that you
could have enjoyed those benefits you
could have prioritized results of the
process but you don't do that you say
that you say that you're the one who
said that in I think it's 20 so no I
preserve the integrity of the European
Union and it's single market into
negotiation with Britain because in 2017
I'll complain that the EU was a
bureaucratic Leviathan and now you seem
today's cheerleader and I seem to be a
cheerleader for it I mean democracy is
messy as you said I mean this is the
receipt okay well yeah but we are
talking about the Demi's we are talking
about the institutions of the first
attempt in the world of having a
transnational democracy do you believe
that is it happens without difficulties
no of course not
with certainly not without but you
already selected EU is pretty selective
about which rules its faces in which it
doesn't give me an example ok let's take
the stability fat pact yes all right
fact is that since it was introduced not
a single year has gone by without at
least one member countries fire rises
breaching EU a guideline remember the
Commission President jean-claude yonkers
and from his claim in 2016 France was
given anyway on because Fras if it is
fraud exactly what your examples example
and I share your criticism about that
because indeed it seems to be a sort of
two-speed judgment on public finances if
you're a big country you will be treated
differently in a small country and
there's evidence to that and so I'm in
2016 when Spain and Portugal breach the
rules Brussels decided to set fines at
what level zero euros exactly what
message did that send that these rules
are not really credible I agree with
your rules when you feel like it and you
enforce them
again when it suits you well it's really
interesting because you you treat me as
if I were the European Union
you know European Union is diverse
there's diversity no democracy there's
people who agree with certain policies
and those who disagree with them and I
happen to agree with some and to
disagree you are in favor I mean yeah
single mark yes but I'm also on record
saying that the budgetary rules of the
European Union are unfit for purpose
that's reality they have no scientific
ground at all we wrote the three-percent
rule so the fact that public budgets but
cannot go over three percent deficit and
public debt cannot go over sixty percent
of GDP and you know what these figures
have exactly zero scientific substance
they are purely arbitrary and so indeed
you cannot do good policies without well
but just based on arbitrary figures so
if these rules are unfit for purpose I
am not that worried that well we play
with them because well they are under
you you play madam yeah let's talk if we
may about human rights because that you
care about you wrote a couple of years
ago that the most powerful breath of
hope for all those who were living under
the oppression of authoritarian regimes
was the European Union well I'm not
anymore is it yeah you're right I mean
when I see more how we are we going bed
with her likes of mohammed al Sisi or or
pootie know Mahmud LCC let's take that
example a couple of days ago you happy
that the people legitimacy absolutely
not absolutely not
so you you rail about it but nothing's
ever done is it well we you continue
with let Association agreements with
Egypt you will hit them you wear it
again you again I mean you can continue
playing that game as if I were the
European Union I am NOT I'm a member of
the European Parliament one of 751 and I
happen to disagree with those policies
and you know I'll just tell you one
thing the number one customers of the
weapons industry in France in Belgium in
the United Kingdom is which country
Saudi Arabia
with a dictatorship being put in place
by Mohammed bin Salman I have taken
risks in my own country saying that we
should have an arms embargo against
Saudi Arabia depriving the main Belgian
weapons producer of its main client we
have taken political risk to stand by
our values yes we did but those values
one merchant share in Sharm el-sheikh
were they no they were perhaps instead
of concentrating on rules and
regulations and protecting the single
market the you should show a bit more
principle I think that that indeed we
should stand by our principles
and again our principles should be
underpinned by our institutions but when
politicians decide to ignore them what
can I do the good news is that well
there's various flavors of political
leaders in Europe and not all of them
are prepared to do just anything to to
just serve their short-term interests
the small wonder that when the EU has
seen as you said before the bureaucratic
Leviathan and doesn't live up to its
human rights principles the number of
people voting in European elections
keeps going down doesn't it and that's
what we're 14 was the lowest ever County
2.6 percent nothing to be proud of is
not no absolutely not we are fighting
Jordan is ever closer Union a lot more
at the same no that's again a
misrepresentation we want more
integration but more not more of the
same because you can have an integration
with different policies pour in their
money into endemically corrupt countries
in bulk in the Balkans no we didn't say
that we didn't say that so I mean you
get you can spend your whole time
putting words in my mouth that I that
that I don't agree with it won't list if
conversations you mean is ever closer
ever closer Union is basically a
statement of fact United Kingdom France
Germany Italy let's take these four
countries are the biggest in Europe
barely 1% of the population H of the
global population I mean those well some
people and you may be part of them maybe
not may think that the United Kingdom
once was a global superpower and will be
one again these days are over over let
me finish the only way for Europeans
to carry any weight on the global scale
facing the putin's of this world facing
the - of this world facing climate
change facing the power of of big
corporates is to act together there is
no way around this if you want to have
Hungary or Poland with their
questionable views on the rule of yo
that's whatever closer union with them
well there's many Democrats in Hungary
again we have a Hungarian government
which is autocratic which is not
respecting the principles of the
European Union which we take the urine
urine in a very different direction from
you but is a union but but I have
confidence that the forces of democracy
of real Democrats in Europe will be
stronger than these autocrats and I hope
they will because indeed has a rise of
populism in Europe doesn't look like it
doesn't well wait for the results of the
2019 elections and then we'll talk you
know you did better in in Bavaria and
you've done a little better in your seat
but there but they're very strong and
they're very powerful and we will see
whether they keep gaining strength and I
doubt it
we'll see people in Europe aren't happy
with the way that the European Union
deals with fraud for instance we had a
new report in January revealed that the
EU lost more than 9 billion euros to
fraud between 2010 2017 Member States
doing very little to prevent or punish
those who were identified as suspects
major issue I agree I agree and you
mentioned that was ours closer Union
gonna do anything about that well it's
not it's not as if closer union is
necessary closer union with that kind of
behavior I mean the United Kingdom would
you advocate dissolving the United
Kingdom because well we observed that at
the moment we are not fighting fraud in
a finding process is that working a lot
of people are talking about dissolving
the United Kingdom yeah well I'm not one
of them
so no it's not because well some
processes don't work well in Belgium
that we saw we should dissolve Belgium
or France or any country so let's fix
them mark Rodriguez prime minister says
less is more he doesn't want to say yeah
I'm more closer Union you know I says do
fewer things better yeah yeah of course
he's been a consultant I've been long
enough in business to recognize that
kind of glossy glossy guys who come with
logan's which mean nothing listen you
don't you don't come you'll see guy
coming with slogans no sorry sorry I've
been there I've been then 22 years in
real business I've seen the the economy
from the inside I've seen I've seen the
the newly built version of globalization
from the inside so you can just say the
time a glossy politician who won't
impress me much won't impress me much
and talk to my well talk to my voters
they will they will make that judgment
as to also read I am will see Philip
Lambert's glossy or not it's good to
have your own conflict zone thank you
much a real pleasure I just enjoyed
every minute of it
[Music]
you
[Music]
you